[Music]
meagan Marco breaks her silence ahead of
the royal wedding there about a million
things with this wedding that aren't
going as planned
after a report surfaced that her father
Thomas Marco would not walk her down the
aisle to marry Prince Harry after having
surgery following a heart attack
Megan set the record straight on
Thursday sharing in a statement quote
sadly my father will not be attending
our wedding
I have always cared for my father and
hope he can be given the space he needs
to focus on his health adding I would
like to thank everyone who has offered
generous messages of support please know
how much Harry and I look forward to
sharing our special day with you on
Saturday this comes after a source told
ET the bride-to-be and Harry had mixed
emotions about her dad's health as they
tried to focus on starting their lives
together I was told by sources close to
Megan last night that she was utterly
heartbroken that she couldn't believe
that this was happening just days before
her wedding still no word on who might
walk Megan down the aisle on her big day
but a source told ET on Wednesday Megan
and Harry are doing everything to focus
on their love for each other at the
moment for us is going to be making sure
that our relationship is always put
first
[Music]
[Applause]